Welcome back everyone James Gunn has been talking
about the new Superman in his Superman Legacy
movie the new version of the Justice League
along with the rest of the major characters
in that Superman Legacy movie like Lex Luthor Lois
Lane so we'll break it all down because we finally
know about some of the cast I'll explain what's
going to happen with Henry Cavill Superman Ben
Affleck's Batman the rest of the previous Justice
League because some of those Snyder verse actors
say that they're coming back and some of them like
Henry Cavill for instance say that they will come
back eventually just not right away if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos The Flash movie is coming
really soon I'm working on a bunch of videos for
that right now and I'll do a movie ticket giveaway
when we get a little bit closer right now they're
actually planning on using the flashpoint twist
in The Flash movie to soft reboot the DC EU Snyder
verse into James Gunn's new DC Phase One of movies
which he's calling DC chapter one he's like the
new Kevin feige of DC movies but he's not copying
the phase terminology but that's basically what
they are it's basically DC Phase One the title of
that DC chapter one is Gods and Monsters which is
a reference to a couple things I'll explain later
in the video the report comes from The Hollywood
Reporter and they're saying that Nicholas Holt
is the new version of Lex Luthor which gives you
an idea for where they're plotting this out like
this is meant to be a 20-something Superman like
year two Superman kind of like the way that Robert
Pattinson's Batman was year two Batman so all the
major characters are either in their 20s or if
they're like parody white or the Kents they're
just like a little bit older Lex Luthor obviously
a little bit older than Superman so Nicholas Holt
a little bit older but still very young Jesse
eisenberg's version of Lexus are also very
young they didn't say whether they'll develop the
character the original way like if he's bald from
the start or if it'll be like a Zack Snyder Jesse
Eisenberg Man of Steel Batman v Superman kind of
thing where he becomes bald during the course
of the new movies but because he is Lex Luthor
he will be one of the biggest antagonists across
the entire universe not just in the new Superman
movies probably the biggest thing in this report
is that the current lead for Superman right now is
actually David cornswith who a lot of people have
been fan casting when the reboot was announced
last year some of you probably been expecting him
for a while James Gunn had previously revealed
that the person that would be his new Superman
wouldn't be any of the typical really big
established actors people would normally expect
for a role like this that just means that he had
always planned on casting a smaller actor like a
relative unknown that hadn't done a ton of major
Comic Book roles before David's biggest stuff
so far is probably that new Pearl horror movie
which is pretty decent the politician series
and David Simon's we owned this city which also
starred John Bernthal Punisher a pretty decent
Series so he's done some decent stuff so far
I'm not super familiar with his work or the actor
himself but I do like the idea that James Gunn is
casting a relative unknown just because when you
cast an established actor they bring all these
preconceived notions about what their Superman is
going to be like and all these ideas about how the
character is going to be probably the best example
of that recently is when The Rock played Black
Adam he didn't so much play Black Adam as much
as he played The Rock in a Black Adam costume in
the way all of the Rock's rolls tend to feel the
same he plays the same character in most of his
movies as opposed to a character actor who feels
completely different in every role they play like
Colin Farrell's penguin in the new Batman movies
his penguin felt so different from his other
roles tonally and just physically visibly that
most people win the first looks and the teaser
started releasing didn't realize it was actually
Colin Farrell talk about disappearing into a role
so it just feels like a smart move James Gunn to
cast a relative unknown it'll be much easier for
him to mold his new Superman performance into the
actual story so that the story and the character
fit a little bit better the new leading pick for
Lois Lane is actually Rachel bro Shannon from The
Marvelous Mrs Mesa which is actually pretty decent
series like she's actually a great actress but a
lot of people are expecting it to be someone else
just because the lowest Lane character will be in
her 20s during the movie like she'll be about
the same age as Superman most of the versions
of the characters will be much younger and Rachel
bro Shannon is on the older side of that she's in
her 30s honestly I don't think it's that big of
a problem like if she's a better actress I would
rather see her play the character really good
example of this like a slightly older Lois Lane
is Amy Adams Lois Lane in Man of Steel if they
were going to do Man of Steel too she obviously
would have been a much older version of Lois Lane
even though Henry Cavill still looks pretty young
honestly it was just like a little bit of makeup
she still seems relatively young so it wouldn't
have been that big a deal James Gunn did say that
some of his Marvel Guardians of the Galaxy actors
will play characters in the upcoming DC movies
and in the Superman Legacy movie but he didn't
say which Guardians of the Galaxy character
would be in his Superman Legacy movie but if
you think about it some of his Guardians of the
Galaxy actors have already been in DC movies some
of them relatively recently like Michael Rooker
Michael Rosenbaum his brother Sean Gunn played
weasel even his Amanda Waller who will continue
in these new DC movies but I think when he said
that he was mostly referring to new actors from
Guardians of the Galaxy that have not been in DC
movies before like Chris Pratt or Zoe Saldana
and I think Chris Pratt would actually make a
pretty decent booster goal old explaining what the
Gods and Monsters terminology means for phase one
the gods part is a reference to characters like
Superman like super power beings who are basically
living God's other Cosmic beings with crazy
levels of power like Darkseid in the monster's
part is a reference to a couple different things
like the idea that Humanity views these Gods as
kind of like Monsters it's also a reference to
actual monster creature based characters like one
of James Gunn's very first DC movies and series
they're going to release in the next couple years
is the Creature Commandos they're literally
a team made of monster-based characters the
first project is Creature Commandos Creature
Commandos is an animated series I've written
all the episodes something we're going to do
that's a little bit different at DC is we're
going to have characters move into animation out
of Animation usually having the same actor play
their voice as who plays them in live action but
also the monster term is a reference to the actual
villains like the regular human villains like
Lex Luthor who act like Monsters even though
they view the Gods in this equation like Superman
as monsters they themselves the regular humans are
acting like Monsters metaphorically my name is
Ezra Miller and I am criminally excited to be
a part of the Justice League really good example
this is the Justice League Gods and Monsters movie
they released a couple years ago it's about an
alternate universe Justice League where zod's
son becomes Superman Man-Bat becomes a version
of Batman and Wonder Woman is the daughter of
Orion one of the new Gods like a way more hardcore
version of the character the people of their world
view them as kind of like Monsters because like
man bat for instance is literally a monster-based
character but the real villain winds up being
will Magnus in the middlemen like a human of
Earth who does villainous monstrous things in the
Justice League which they had viewed as monsters
wind up saving everyone proven to be good so
the people wind up being the real monsters it
just sounds like that's going to be the vibe in
the this new Justice League universe that James
Gunn is rebooting the rest the regular people like
Amanda Waller think of the new Justice League the
same way that Zack Snyder's Lex Luthor thought
of Henry Cavill Superman kind of like a monster
the whole deal with Lex Luthor and this is the
same for every different TV show every comic
book every medium that you've seen them in with a
few exceptions like there have been a couple else
worlds versions of Lex Luthor who wind up being
really good but in most versions of the character
like even Michael rosenbaum's version of Lex
during Smallville the reason why they don't like
Superman is because they feel like when Superman
showed up the world stopped dealing with its own
problems and depending on him to save them from
everything so it made Humanity weaker so like
every version of Lex Luthor for the most part
thinks of himself as the greatest humanitarian
it's just that the links he goes to the evil the
terrible things that he does to try and get rid
of Superman and cause the world to turn against
him wind up driving him to overt villainy during
the Justice League starter cut when Zack Snyder
was still planning on making Justice League 2 and
Justice League 3 they revealed the story for that
he was actually going to get into that during his
movies where Lex Luthor in his Injustice League
wind up working with Darkseid to get rid of the
Justice League at least for a little while until
the Justice League eventually prevails Zack Snyder
revealed a much more deleted scenes about his
Justice League Trilogy I did a video about that
so I'll link it below in the description the
reason Henry Cavill isn't going to be Superman
and Superman Legacy is mostly because he is meant
to be a much much younger version of the character
when they made the initial announcement about the
reboot Henry kappel did say that he was sad to
leave the role of Superman at least temporarily
but that he had talked to James Gunn about
returning in the future like the distant future I
think what he's talking about is an else world's
crisis on infinite Earth's kind of twist because
the whole idea is that all these new movies like
Superman Legacy Batman Brave and the Bold that
James Gunn is doing those will be the versions
that you see in the new version of the Justice
League so when Henry Cavill is saying that he'll
eventually come back way down the road it would
have to be in elseworld's kind of twist probably
I mean they could recast him as another role like
a version of jorel but I think what he was talking
about coming back he was talking about coming
back as a version of his Superman I wanted to wait
until the weekend was over before posting this so
uh there's a lot to be thankful for and I'll get
to that in time but I want to thank you guys most
of all thank you for your support and thank you
for your patience I promise it will be rewarded it
does suck to see him go I would have loved to see
Man of Steel too I've done a couple videos about
what that movie would have been they've been a
lot of plans made some announcements about what
their plot was going to be even though he's also
leaving The Witcher he just announced the brand
new Warhammer series the recent trailer for that
I just did a video for that so I'll link it at
the end of this but there's a bunch of new Flash
trailers with a ton of new footage so I'll do
videos for those as quickly as possible there'll
be a bunch of Blue Beetle trailers really soon
everyone post all your reactions in the comments
below if you have any questions about what's
going on and click here for that brand new Henry
Cavill Warhammer trailer video and click here for
all my new Flash trailer videos and Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!